دعت الامم المتحده طرفي الصراع في السودان
الى التفاوض لانهاء الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن
وحذرت من ان استمرار الصراعي لم يؤدي الا
لتدمير البلاد كما نبهت الامم المتحده الى
خطوره اثار الحرب على المدنيين ياتي هذا
بالتزامن مع تصاعد المواجهات المسلحه بين
طرفي القتال في الفتره الاخيره وتوقف مسار
جده للحوار بين الجيش والدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما اسباب تصاعد وتيره
المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع مؤخرا
وتباعد فرص التسويه المتفاوض عليها في ظل
توقف مسار جده للحوار من اجل انهاء القتال
ما هي التاثيرات الداخليه والدوليه
المحتمله للتصعيد الراهن في وتيره
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان بالنظر الى
توسع ساحات الصراع وارتفاع كلفته
الانسانيه بل مسارات المحتمله للوضع في
السودان على ضوء الاوراق التي يراهن عليها
كل من طرفي الصراع وما ماذا توفر مؤشرات
ترجح قدره اي منهما على الحسم العسكري
[موسيقى]
غادرت اشتباكات وصفت بانها من بين الاعنف
في ام درمان منذ اندلاع الحرب قبل نحو
اربعه اشهر بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي
ظل تصعيد ملحوظ في القتال بين طرفيه
تزامنا مع توقف مسار جده للحوار بينهما
تواصلت الاشتباكات بين الجانبين يوم
الاربعاء في مواقع مختلفه من العاصمه
الخرطوم وبمختلف انواع الاسلحه وفي ظل
التضارب المستمر في تقارير طرفي القتال
بشان نتائج المواجهات تواصل سقوط المدنيين
قتلى وجرحى نتيجه استمرار المعارك وارتفاع
حدتها واتساع رقعتها وتوالت التحذيرات
بشان الاثار الانسانيه المروعه للحرب التي
تقول التقارير الدوليه ان ملايين الاشخاص
غادروا منازلهم جراءها بين نازح ولاجئ وان
نحو نصف سكان البلاد باتوا بحاجه للمساعده
بسببها
في جلسه لمجلس الامن الدولي دعت اليها
بريطانيا واكدت واشنطن ضروره عقدها من اجل
بحث تطورات الاوضاع في السودان دعت الامم
المتحده طرفي الصراع للتفاوض من اجل انهاء
الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن مساعده الامين العام
للامم المتحده لشؤون الافريقيه حذرت في
الجلسه من ان استمرار الحرب سيزيد من خطر
التشردم والتدخل الاجنبي وفقدان مستقبل
السودان واضافت المسؤوله الامميه ان ايا
من طرفي الحرب لم يحقق مكاسب ملموسه فيها
وان الدعوه لاستمرارها لن تؤدي الا لتدمير
البلاد
[موسيقى]
هناك قلق
من ان الدف العنف
يتزايد
وان الجهود للتوصل الى
تراجعت
وبالرغم من محاوله دفع الطرفين المتصارعين
لكي
يعود السودان الى وضع يختار فيه الشعب
حكامه
وذلك ما نامل اليه ولكنني اشعر بقلق شديد
حول مسار العنف حاليا في السودان وهو
يرتفع في هذه المرحله سيد محمد ما الذي
يسهم في تساقط حده المواجهات بين الطرفين
في البدله التحيه لك ولضيفك الكريم
والساده المشاهدين الاقارم هو بلال شك
هنالك عده عوامل اسهمت بشكل مباشر في
تصاعد حده المواجهات العسكريه مؤخرا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع اهمها
انا في تقديري
الاستراتيجيه التي كانت تتبع القوات
المسلحه المرتبطه ارتباط وثيق
بالاستراتيجيه الدفاع عن المقرات الاجهزه
العسكريه والامنيه والى حد ما مقار اجهزه
الدوله الان تغيرت بعد اكثر من ثلاث اشهر
من المواجهات العسكريه وربما كانت الاخوات
المسلحه تعتمد على سياسه النفس الطويل او
سياسه الاستنزاف انهاك العدو وعندما ادركت
بان حان الوقت للتحرك باستخدام قدر اكبر
من القوه وذلك وفقا للتصريحات التي صدرت
من القيادات من البرهان وكذلك العطاء
وغيرهم بانهم سيستخدمون القوى المميته
ربما هذه هي مؤشرات القوه المميته
بيستخدموا قدر عالي جدا من القوى الامر
الذي يؤثر على شكل كبير جدا على حياه
المدنيين في بعض الاحيان الجزئيه الاخرى
وهي المهمه بحيث ان طرفيه الصراع ما زالوا
يفضلون الخيار العسكري لحسم مجريات
المعركه في ظل تراجع فرص الحلول
الدبلوماسيه والسياسيه لاسيه تاخر او
تراجع مهمين الذي لم يستانف فيه الحوار او
التفاوض منذ فتره بعيده في ظل تراجع ايضا
مبادره الايجاد وما زالت المبادره دول
جوار السودان لم تشكل بلوره كامله
لمواقفها بالرغم ان الاجتماع وزرع
الخارجيه بالامس في انجمينا نتحدث عن ثلاث
نقاط متمثله في وقف اطلاق النار واجراء
حوار سياسي شامل بين القوه السياسيه
والملف الانساني كثلاث نقاط مهمه جدا لكن
الان التحدي بيضمن هل هذه المبادرات
تستطيع ان تتضاف بعضها البعض لا سيما
معابر جده حتى يتم اطلاق النار وكذلك شروط
وفي اطلاق النار باعتبار ان هذه الجزئيه
معقده جدا اذا كان العشره هدى السابقه لم
تحقق النجاحات اللازمه المرتبطه بفتح
الممرات انسانيه وايقافه المدنيين
فبالتالي هذه الجزيره ربما السودان اشارت
الى انها لديها بعض الامكانيات بعض
القدرات المتمثله بقدرتها على تحديد
مسارات وممرات انسانيه وكذلك اجراء حوار
سياسي فانا في تقدير هذه الجزئيات مهمه
اذا تسرع اذا تسارعت الخطى نحو ذلك
النجمه ساعود اليها سيد محمد سيد مايكل
حوار جدا شهد جولات عديده الان متوقف في
ظل هذا التصعيد الحاصل بين الطرفين تقارير
تتحدث بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والسعوديه تبلوران صيغه
للحل هل يمكن ان نفهم
ما هي استراتيجيه او صيغه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اولا لعوده وفد السودان
الى هذا الحوار حوار جده وثانيا لحل
المساله في التفاوض في جده
ان الجهد الامريكي
يتماشى مع قلته نحتاج اولا وقفا لاطلاق
النار وان يكون هناك دعم انساني للمحتاجين
المشكل بالنسبه لوقفه تلاقي النار لدينا
طرفان متصارعان لا احد منهما يسيطر على
الاخر وذلك يزيد من دوامه العنف
واذا
اذا دافئ
دعم بلدان هذا الطرف او ذاك الامر يصعب
التوصل الى حل بشانه ينبغي ان يتوقف مد اي
من الطرفين بالاسلحه
حتى
يعود الى المفاوضات ثانيا عندما يتعلق
بالمساعدات الانسانيه
هناك
مشاكل عديده
خاصه دعم الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وهو
ما يقلل من الدعم وجميع البلدان ينبغي ان
تضمن ان الاوكرانيين يمكنهم ان يصدروا
حبوبهم
لان ذلك سيساهم في حل ازمه الغذاء
اذا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
سوف يركزان على ذلك
وسيتطلب من ذلك من الجانبين ان يوافق على
ذلك لكن ينبغي ان يكون هناك ضغوط اضافيه
من قبل الطرفين ومن قبل الدول الاخرى حتى
يتم التوصل الى مثل هذا الحل سيد محمد
الجيش عندما سحب وفده من جده قال انه
للتشاور ثم عاد وقال بانه لن يشارك الا
اذا تمت الاستجابه لشروطه ما هذه الشروط
التي دائما تؤخر مسار جدا بتقديرك
انا في تقديري قضيه انسحاب قوات الدعم
السريع من الاحياء وكذلك المنشات الصحيه
والمدنيه والخدميه هذه نقطه ظلت خلافيه
الوساطه للاسف الشديد لم تتمكن من ايجاد
حلها لا سيما فيما يتعلق بخروج الدعم
السريع من الاحياء الى اين تذهب مع العلم
ان قوات الدعم السريعه
عدم عدم مشاركه وفد الجيش في هذا الحوار
ايضا لا لا يسحب القوات من من الاحياء
السكنيه كما يقول الجيش
هو هو بلا شك انا في تقديري هذه الجزئيه
مرتبطه ينبغي للوساطه ان تفعل ادواتها
ووسائلها لكن انا في تقدير ربما رؤيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي دائما ما
تعتقد بان الدعم السريع هي مليشه لديها
سجل من الانتهاكات والفظائع وفي الجانب
الاخر تتهم الجيش السوداني بانه مؤدلج لذا
هي لم تطرح قضيه فعليه متمثله في انسحاب
الدعم السريع وكذلك ممارسه الضغوط على
القوات المسلحه حتى يتثنى للطرفين للتواصل
الى موقع او موقف تفاوطي موضوع او محل
تقدير لدى من بعد الوصول الى تفاهمات
فبالتالي انا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
ربما تعتقد بان كلما استمرت المعرفه كلما
حدث استنزاف لطرفي الصراع بشكل كبير جدا
ومن بعد ما نستهل جدا يمكن للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن طريق منبر عن طريق
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ايضا ان تفرض
شروط ميشانها اعاده سياقه هيكله
السوداني والاستمرار في المسار السياسي
المرتبط باكمال الفتره الانتقاليه لذا نفي
تقديري ربما الظروف المواتيه
مساله وخفي اطلاق النار بشكل مستمر
والشروع الجاده في المفاوضات التي تتناول
الجوانب السياسيه والفنيه للدمج الدعم
السريع في الجيش ربما لم تنضج بالشكل
الكافي لذا هنالك عدم جديه في سير
المفاوضات خروج او عودته الى السودان كان
هو بمثابه انسحاب من المفاوضات لكن
دبلوماسيه الجيش صرح بانه لمزيد من
التجاربين
سيد مايكل
هل يستطيع مجلس الامن ان يبقى متفرجا هكذا
ومتكل على حوار جدا من جهه او على مبادره
ايكاد والاتحاد الافريقي المرفوضه من طرف
الجيش السوداني اليوم مساعده الامين العام
لانه المتحده لشؤون الافريقيه رسمت صوره
سوداويه نصف سكان السودان بحاجه لمساعدات
ملايين تركوا منازلهم الى متى
سيقف المجلس مجلس الامن والمجتمع الدولي
متفرجا على ما يحصل في السودان
الامم المتحده
لن ترسل بطبيعه الحال اي قوه حفظ سلام حتى
يكون هناك اتفاق ووقف وانطلاق النار
يمكن ان
يسلط عقوبات
واذا كانت كان احد الاطراف يرفض العقوبات
فلن تطبق بالنسبه للسؤال الذي سالته
سالتني اياهم قبل ان قوات الدعم السريع
ينبغي ان تخرج من المناطق السكنيه
وهناك لا يمكن ان
يستهدفوا وسيؤدي ذلك الى قتل العديد ايقاع
العديد من الضحايا في المدى الطويل معظم
ما رايناه يعمل هو ان يكون هناك دمج لهذه
القوات حتى يكون للجنود من
الطرفين مكان يكون فيه
ويتم دمجها في القوات المسلحه
والقوات المسلحه ينبغي ان تدعم المسار
الديمقراطي لكن الجنراللين
لا يفعل ذلك
والمجتمع الدولي يود ان يحدث ذلك لكن
السؤال هو هل ان ذلك سوف
لن يتم الا عندما يوافق الطرفان على وقف
لاطلاق النار هو فقط التوضيح انا لم اطرح
عليك سؤالا عن الدعم السريع وتواجده في
الاحياء بل جاءت بمداخله السيد محمد سيد
محمد الكلفه العاليه لسقوط المدنيين في
السودان خاصه اخيرا في في ام درمان مثل
الاحياء في ابروف ومقالته
مساعده الامين العام
شؤون الافريقيه هل ممكن ان يسرع الحل هل
ممكن ان يبلور تدخلا
يضع حدا لهذا الصراع القائم الذي يدفع
ثمنه المدنيون في السودان
وربما يعني يجعل المجتمع الدولي يحاول ان
يتحرك لكن معلوم انه الان المجتمع الدولي
لاسيوم ولا الدول التي تمتلك حق النقد
الفيتو في مجلس الامن الدولي بينها تقاطع
كبير للمصالح الاسهم في اطار عنا افريقيا
الان اصبح الساحه لديناميه الصرع الدولي
فبالتالي الان في جلسه مجلس الامن كانوا
موقف روسيا واضحا يتحدث بضروره ان لا يتم
التدخل في الشام السوداني وما الى ذلك
الموقف الصيني ربما اكثر دبلوماسيه لكن
ايضا ارسل اشارات في هذا السياق وفي هذا
الاتجاه اعرف تقدير الان الامم المتحده
وكذلك مجلس الامن الدولي مشغول بقضاء اخرى
قضايا التعقيدات وتاثيرات اكبر ربما من
القضيه السودانيه وتداعياتها على امن
الاستقرار القاره الافريقي هو منطقه القرن
الافريقي والاخص لكن التكلفه الانسانيه
العاليه
بتجعل تقدير الطرفيه الصراع النظر في كثير
من
المسائل المرتبطه باستخدام القوه
المميته او كذلك
المدفعيه الثقيله وبعض الوسائل التي بلا
شك ستكون عواقبها او تداعيات الانسانيه
كبيره جدا وانا في تقدير ما حدث بالامس في
ام درمان فقط ام درمان هي
بتمتلك قدر كامل وقدري كبير جدا من ارسال
وكذلك عكس الذي يحدث على الارض في وسائل
الاعلام هما الى ذلك لكن مثل هذه العمليات
مثل هذه المعارك المستمره في ذهل انقطاع
كامل للخدمات من كهرباء والانتصارات وكذلك
للمياه وما الى ذلك ظلت تقع في دارفور
وكذلك هنالك انتهاكات وهنالك جرائم حرب
جرائم ضد الانسانيه فاظلت ترتكب في كل مدن
دارفور لكن دارفور نتيجه لبعدها عن
الخرطوم عدم توفر وسائل الاعلام وصحفيين
مستقلين جعلوا الصوره لا تصل الى المجتمع
الدولي وكذلك المجتمع بالشكل الكافي لكن
اؤكد لك بان هنالك فضائح هنالك عدد كبير
جدا من القتلى لم يصل تصل ارقامهم حتى الى
الاعلام في ظل غياب كامل للوكالات الامم
المتحده المعنيه بايصال المساعدات وكذلك
تقديم الخدمات للمدنيين ناحيه ناهيك عن
النازحين المتواجدين في السودان حتى
اللاجئين الموجودين في شرق الشاشات
والموجودين في اثيوبيا وما الى ذلك لم تصل
وكالات الامم المتحده لتقديم اللاقات لهم
لذا الان ينبغي على المجتمع الدولي ان
يتحرك للتقديم المعاونات للمحتاجين لانهم
فقدوا كل شيء لا سيما المتواجدين في مناطق
امنه وفي ولايات وسط السودان وكذلك
اللاجئين في افريقيا الوسطى وفي اثيوبيا
في جلسه مجلس الامن قالت مساعده الامين
العام للشؤون الافريقيه ان اي من طرفي
النساء لم يحقق مكاسب على الارض هل هناك
اي مؤشرات على ان طرف يستطيع ان يحسم
المعركه عسكريا على الارض في ظل غياب
الحلول السياسيه حتى الان
لسوء الحظ هذه المشكله التي اثرتها هناك
طرفان
متعادلان من ناحيه القوه ولا احد منهم
يمكنه ان يحسم النزاع
وعندما يكون هناك بلدان تدعم هذا هذا
الجانب واخر تدعى الجانب الاخر فان ذلك
يزيد من مده النزاع وهذا يضر بشكل خاص
بالشعب ما نود ان نراه والمجتمع الدولي ان
يرى وقفا لاطلاق النار حتى تبدا المفاوضات
وحتى يتم ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه وهذا
سيكون حاجه هناك حاجه اكيده اليه وهنا
الامم المتحده وجميع الاطراف المعنيه
بانتهاء النزاع في السودان ينبغي ان تركز
عليه في الوقت الحاضر ليس هناك
اي فرصه لاي طرفه من الطرفين ليحسب الامر
وما دام يحصلان على دعم فان ذلك سيطيل مدى
النزاع سيد محمد ليس فقط تصريح المسؤوله
الامميه بل ايضا الواقع الارض يقول بانه
يستطع اي طرف ان يحقق مكاسب تخوله من حسم
المساله لاسيما في العاصمه الخرطوم على
ماذا يعول كل طرف اذا داخليا خاصه
قوات الجيش الجيش السوداني الذي
يعني يفرض شروطا على حوار جده
[موسيقى]
مرتبطه ايضا بوقوع عدد كبير جدا من
الضحايا وكذلك عدم قدره المدنيين من تلقي
الاحتياجات اللازمه نتيجه لان حتى الان
العاملين في الخدمه المدنيه وحتى العاملين
في القطاع الخاص لا يستطيعون ممارسه
وظائفهم وما الى ذلك لذا انا في تقديري
هذه المعطيات ربما هي التي تجعل الجيش
يتمسك بهذا الموقف فالمرتبط بدمج الدعم
السريع وفقا لشراط المؤسسه العسكريه
وهنالك جزئيه وهي الاهم وان القوات
المسلحه وهنالك اتجاهات واسعه استطاعت
انها تجيش الراي العام السوداني بضروره ان
يكون الحسن حسما عسكريا وهذه ايضا من
الاشكاليات التي جعلت المؤسسه العسكريه ان
حديثه عن اي بادره من بوادر التفاوض او
محاوله معالجه هذا
السيد مايكل اشار قبل قليل الى دعم طرفي
الصراع بالمال وايضا بالسلاح مندوب السداف
الامم المتحده تحدث اليوم صراحه عن ان
دوله
اقليميه تؤجج الصراع في السودان اللافت
بان حتى الان الحكومه لم تسمي هذه الدوله
لماذا لا تسميها وتحملها المسؤوليه على
مراى ومسمع من المجتمع الدولي
السؤال ليهم للطرف
انا في تقدير الازمه في السودان هي واضحه
المعالم ومعلومه تماما ان قوات الدعم
السريع هي تتوفر لها دعم ويتوفر لها دعم
خارجي وغطاء خارجي متمثل في دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده وانا في تقدير الله
الجانب السوداني والحكومه السودانيه ممثله
في الجيش او في وزاره الخارجيه لم تقل ذلك
صراحه لان ذلك لديه او فيه تبعات متمثله
ربما الامارات تخطر خطوه اخرى وتقطع
العلاقات وتبدا وبدعم الدعم بشكل اكثر لكن
معلوم الدعم السريعي يجد الدعم والتمويل
من الامارات عن طريق خليفه حفتر وكذلك عن
طريق حتى الان هنالك بعض المعلومات عن
طريق جات في بعض المطارات المجاوره
للسودان فهذا معلوم والجانب السوداني او
الجيش السوداني مدعومه مسنود الى حد كبير
من مصر فهذه هي المعلومات المهمه فضلا عن
ذلك هنالك تورط بشكل او باخر من اثيوبيا
والامارات لكن
وكينيا لكن نتيجه لطبيعه الصراعات او الا
ضطرابات الداخليه التي تعيشها الان
اثيوبيا وكينيا جعلت كانت دولتين
مشغولتانهم الداخليه سؤال كذلك في الجانب
الاخر معلوم تماما ان الدعم الامارات
للسودان هو مبر وفقا لتوجهت السياسه
الخارجيه الاماراتيه لسببين سبب الاول هو
سبب اقتصاد الامارات منذ فتره اطلقت
استراتيجيه متمثله فانها
محورات المحتمله لهذا الصراع في ظل تاجيجه
داخليا وغياب الحوار حتى الان باقتضاض
شديد لو سمحت
اعتقد ان توقعات هي انها
ستكون هناك
استمرار
للمعارك لانه لا احد من الطرفين يمكنه ان
يحسم الامر وذلك سيلحق ضررا كبيرا بالشعب
السوداني ويجعل من الصعب وصول المساعدات
الانسانيه شكرا لكما في مونتانا مايكل
نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
ومن باريس محمد تورشينا الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني الى هنا تنتهي الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لحسن المتابعه
الى اللقاء بامان الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]